as california goes
that's the focus of tonight's angle
if you want to know where america is
headed if we don't turn the tide against
biden's socialist regime
look no further than right here in
california
now i brought the show here because
americans need to understand where we're
headed with the democrats in charge
for better or worse the golden state has
always led the way culturally
politically and yes morally
the american dream in many ways it began
right here in california
now it wasn't just the land of sunshine
surfing usa and beautiful people
but from the gold rush to the tech boom
it was a place that epitomized america's
potential and limitless opportunities
but after a decade of democrats
dominating every branch of government
here it's all unraveling
today's california consists of a tiny
sliver of super wealthy people
a growing underclass
and a rapidly shrinking middle class
that's fed up and running for the exits
so for all their claims of being
progressive
california though is among the most
regressive states in the country
over the past decade eighty percent of
the state's jobs have paid under median
wage half of which are paid less than
forty thousand dollars and most
are in poorly paid personal services or
hospitality jobs even at some of the
state's most prestigious companies like
google
many lower and even mid-level workers
live in mobile home parks
others sleep in their cars
and thousands upon thousands of people
now live on the streets we're going to
take you inside the homelessness crisis
swamping this city later on the show
now it's so bad that even democrat
voters may finally be waking up let me
work let me pay my taxes but provide me
with safety and not be accosted by two
homeless people within the matter of 15
minutes is this governor newsome's fault
i mean
technically how can i even answer that
he's the leader it's it's everything
starts from the top
and it goes down
well democrats should be very worried
because their defund the police crusade
has led to skyrocketing crime those
women are feeling it
in l.a murders are up nearly 24
shootings are up almost 38
now in san francisco where we were just
earlier this week shootings are up 105
during the first half of this year alone
so police they're understaffed and
outgunned
and at the same time we've left
left-wing da's to run a walk people like
chesa boudin in san francisco and george
gascon here in la total travesties
they're more focused on letting the
criminals walk free than seeing them
locked up and off the streets
the people who are arresting
are on probation
they're on the electronic ankle
monitoring by the probation department
and it still doesn't deter them from
going out and
committing these crimes
because they know the district attorney
won't do anything so it's a revolving
door of criminality absolutely 24 48
hours often times these people if
they're arrested will be back out of
jail
before the police officers are done
right in their police report
it's not just a crime in the
homelessness though democrats policies
from lockdowns to high taxes punish
small business owners and entrepreneurs
as well
and when governor gavin newsom is asked
to explain why so many people are
leaving for the red states
he just gets dismissive and defensive we
have better health outcomes in florida
and texas and better economic outcomes
i'm proud of the fact we actually have a
housing policy and homeless policy for
the first time in decades everybody
outside this state
is about this state because of our
success
go back to plump jack winery my friend
oh by the way and they also literally
can't keep the lights on or water
running here
under newsom the state saw its first
rolling blackout since 2001 thanks in
part to insane left-wing climate
policies the state faces a potential
supply shortfall of about 2.6 million
households forcing gruesome newsom to
allow industrial facilities to run on
diesel generators that's great for the
environment
so much for going green
things are so desperate here that newsom
is now paying people
to cut down on energy use i kid you not
but it's not billionaires like oprah
winfrey up in montecito or mark
zuckerberg who get hit by the democrats
growth killing taxes or greniac measures
they don't care about that they're so
rich it's the middle class that gets hit
california's energy and climate rigs are
so crippling to working families
especially minorities
they've actually been dubbed the green
jim crow
and larry elder the leading republican
in the september 14th recall effort aims
to turn all of this around
what's your first thing you're going to
do
to the extent that there are any
statewide mandates for mass wearing and
for vaccine for state workers they're
going to be repealed i'm going to
declare a public emergency on
homelessness i'm going to declare a
public emergency on water
more from the candidate from his old
neighborhood in just a few
moments what we're revealing to you
tonight is a cautionary tale
the media is shilling for newsome and
the teachers unions and big tech bank
rolling the war chest
that's happening but none of that can
change the fact the truth that
california is dying a slow and painful
death
but a political backlash is brewing
the people still have the power to turn
the tide now is the time to throw the
leftist bums out
and california can lead the nation once
again by sending a powerful message to
the political establishment
push us too far
and we'll push you out
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else